maybe not maybe he's just totally
focused he obviously played absolutely
insane in the last match that we saw but
we're going to dragon's nest as well
weird walls
yeah super creamer here you know he's
sitting pretty right now in that toc
leaderboard in number one with 400
points um so for him it's this is just
about winning the master event you know
it's about pride um you know his lead is
not going to be challenged by anyone in
my opinion but here we go guys there's a
2d match up here we're going to see air
to airs fireballs and all sorts have you
gone
yeah commentator is nightmare man if you
practice tech and commentary forget it
forget it all right
here we go
okay time for one a big block there
already super akuma coming out of the
gates and just showing dominance right
now yeah
okay
wow
that worked
[Music]
yeah yeah kirk is so afraid now of the
lows
[Music]
forward
sending them dark waves wow
he's not gonna have any issues with that
has a backer there for himself
oh the jump in what uh disgusting
nice
there's been a bit of a scrambling this
is what super kimmer does too when you
play him he does make it into a really
messy scrambly tekken match man yeah
like a jam sandwich with too jam on it
but look at that wow big dp gonna send
it up yeah i think that was a punish as
well that's
might be guaranteed i'm not sure if
maybe the meter comes out a nice ant
here here we go okay
two bars now for kirakira definitely
needs to start using them
okay oh could have got more there man
that one two is launched punishable but
either way kira will get the combo here
is he gonna be the kill i don't think so
unless he gets the wall the wall yeah oh
wow
oh my god wow big statement piece there
from kirakira to knock a perfect out of
super akuma that's expensive
absolutely two possible to work with as
well here super cool we're gonna get the
down through the touch of death this is
gonna be a big damage yeah he's gonna
get the wall here as well he just framed
look dad half off man
yeah
okay down three is now coming out
close
uh-oh two bars a meter as well kira
kiran needs to wake up here and start
using them there's one
30 seconds left
fashion
back dashing up here here we go
yes sir
okay a lot of damage there
oh boy all right
he killed him so fast he just killed him
so fast man i saw kirakira with a little
bit of
flash of life in his eyes and that and
now uh and then super cool i just went
nah nah just down three bruh yeah
you never have the live feed against his
character if he has meter he's got you
know that down three always available
yeah
it's so funny the difference in in play
styles if you're playing against an
akuma to when they have meter and when
they don't have meter like when they
don't have meter you're just like ah
you're you're almost kind of like you
know handicapped in a sort of a way like
you know your hands are tied behind your
back and as soon as you hear that
you're like all right back up back up
everyone you know battle stations ready
here we go guys you know it's going to
be a storm yeah i would like to see uh
eliza maybe akira jump back a little bit
more you know like he hasn't been using
his own jumpings a lot uh that would
have gotten out of that situation
potentially with the down three um but
yeah in certain situations you have to
take the mix up right when your tech
roll we saw that with uh akuma in his in
his previous matches uh when he had
tattoo at the wall
yeah the down through is extremely scary
man it's definitely one like one of the
scariest moves in tekken just because
it's a 15 frame high crushing low poke
uh on on on it's on it's hey i know
you're laughing i know exactly why
you're laughing just just hearing it
makes you laugh but i mean um it has to
be clean here of course but when you're
at the wall it's going to be difficult
but i see i feel like kira michael to
the infinite age i just get rid of the
walls now
and that big potential for damage from
akuma yeah i love the the story about
super akuma is has had the infinite
stage picked against him so many times
that he's just now become super
comfortable on the infinite stage just
because he beats people in the first
game so often that you know he's just
he's cool on it he's like yeah cool
grind infinite stage no problem and look
at that ladies and gentlemen man i i
like this man
this is a nice little addition to the
tournament absolutely i love it all
right let's go man so kiran now are we
gonna see more defense from him he's
been very aggressive this whole
tournament is he gonna go back to his
normal kirakira
playstyle i mean maybe we'll have to see
i thinks back your idea of the jump
packs is probably gonna be good here
and see some sidewalking coming on oh
but the dp answers back yeah that again
is one of the things that makes akuma
good in this matchup is that the dp is a
guaranteed punishment situation you
don't have to take the mix off yeah
oh nice punish there
again that's the punish as well you
don't have to take the mixture i know
there's a demeanor
wow as i'm saying as soon as he gets me
there ladies and gentlemen you better
run for the hills yeah
it's so very scary but out of the air
with the tip of the toes there oh we're
looking for some uh
some saucy little uh resets there
akuma definitely done his research on
this matchup man his punishment has been
on point kirakara are we gonna start to
see some jump backs here
i think we need to see something here
um okay otg yes sir big ex dive kick
gonna pull him off the ground here so we
can get a comment oh
nice oh no
okay but watch it he's got a bar he's
got a barometer but wait
they trade in favor of kirakira one one
on the round
once again it's that raw jumping from
super creamer and kira is reacting with
the standing four anti-air beautiful
stuff there evens up the rounds but i
still would like to see a bit more
jump-ins when kumar gets in
yeah or jump out jump backs rather
big jump backs very defensive move but
look at watch this damage here just off
one bar
oh maybe not maybe not maybe akuma uh
just a very very difficult character to
kind of execute those super high damage
combos and stuff so i understand it but
he's got a bar again and he just takes
him out with the lows here super kuma
one round away from knocking kirakira
out of it straight away in with the bar
meter yeah that down two they're gonna
catch kirakira on counter here and he's
looking very comfortable now super akuma
just pure attacking us down forward ones
[Music]
once again he dies with two full meters
on he leaves the tournament with two
full meters super akuma moving on in the
bracket and unfortunately commiserations
to kirakira he's going to be home with a
fifth place finish definitely nothing to
uh